Daniel Nora did ski is a [ __ ] prophet
he said immediately that xqc will likely
go with the Scotch open and he did so I
had the counter play and he immediately
blundered well that's got to be a world
record
thanks for the fat ten gift subs Pikachu
my [ __ ] is throbbing throbbing okay so
that's good information let me paste in
the next game let's take a game where
actually see what's black against a
different opponent let's see okay let's
take a game that he won and he's
definitely a 1.e4 player so that's and
let me know if you see the new game
pasted in yo just changed perfect okay
so X you see is with black here he does
play the Russian game okay so by the way
if he does this against you and you have
white do you remember what this was a
bishop moving up here he didn't play the
Petrov's right but do you do you
remember no no but that previous game
X's he was white here X you see is black
and he actually does petrol okay so do
you remember the move against the pet
shop here his opponent plays d4 which is
not the move that that you should be
playing if he plays the petrov yeah you
push the pawn up to defend red actually
as you take the pawn and I was
definitely looking at a different game
yeah hundred percent oh we're good now
now we have both knights on each follow
in alliance yeah sorry about the frogs
did like sometimes doesn't align and
this you remember this trap so if he
plays into this he might actually
blunder his queen and you win the Queen
in the opening so this is what I would
suggest now his opponent plays d4 and
now xqc captures and now he captures the
free pawn his opponent brings his Queen
out xdc defense tonight so X you see
playing well so far and his opponent
blunders a piece here by castling now
what should white have done in this
position
he should have pushed these c-pawn cx-9
and you're you're much sharper than
before at basically identifying threats
and stopping this I'm happy to see that
and hear xqc instead of dropping the
bishop back he plays rook e8 so he
literally blunders the special okay so
here's what I've diagnosed about xqc so
far just from these two games excuse
ECEs you know like he sees moves that
create a threat obviously so you see
this move Queen after me right mm-hmm
it's obvious that this move threatens
the knight but one of his opponents play
a subtle move that doesn't seem
intimidating xqc has a hard time
understanding how the position has
changed and so he's very likely to
blunder at peace so what you need to be
looking for are and somebody saying sir
you might be black if you were white in
the first game so that might be possible
but what you need to try to do is make
these subtle moves that create kind of a
hidden threat right it cuts the Queen
off from the bishop you might not notice
that and that's what happens here is
opponent wins back to piece is that kind
of make sense yeah but that is very odd
yeah and his opponent now drives the
Queen end while white is white is
attacking here but xqc Wiggles out of it
so 93 attacking the Queen his opponent
playing perfectly well here that King is
super weak xqc blundering pawns
yeah his opponent just had a great
position until he blundered a queen in
one move so what should white have done
here in this position white can actually
win another pawn here with a to move
sequence let's see if you can find it
mmm is it just pushing over to the H I
didn't see that you can do that or you
can give a check on c7 and then take on
g7 and that actually simultaneously
defends this pawn Obito
oh so that's a much stronger move then
it is yeah so that's uh that's good now
people in my trad are telling me that
you will most likely be black so let's
actually prioritize the games for XGC
was white and i will actually prepare
you and tell you what xdc is likely to
play
okay and okay you know what I'm gonna do
this professionally I'm gonna do it as
if I was [ __ ] playin and for that you
need to give me like 30 more seconds
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
download X Q sees last hundred games
okay I'm gonna put them into what's
called chess base that's a professional
program that Grand Master's use to
prepare and it processes large numbers
of games and I am going to and there is
a feature on chess fish which basically
tells you what xqc does in certain
positions and it's some in-depth [ __ ]
there's some high-tech [ __ ] well it's a
you know it's the first thing basically
and sorry if I'm like over explaining
this but in chess space there is a
database called mega base that contains
tens of millions of chess games that
have been recorded and posted into this
database so there's a lot of my games
they're all grandmasters have their
games in in mega base but xqc was full
due respect has not made it into mega
base and online games don't make it into
mega base it's only over the board but
it's also kind of a program that allows
you to process things and prepare so I
am actually doing that right now and
people in my chai you're seeing me on XC
C's game page now I'm loading so I'm
gonna make a database I'm not gonna
share my screen while I'm doing that so
it'll just take me one minute let's go
exbc recent games and we'll just do a
hundred games that should be enough
that's probably every game he's played
so far yeah this plate actually 399
total so that actually does play a lot
that's a that's a lot more than I
expected that is some girthy [ __ ] right
there I mean man
okay so let's last hundred games I've
chosen them and now we're going to look
at what he plays xqc prepare there's a
feature called prepare against white and
it tells me so all of the hundred games
53 of them were the white pieces in 52
he played one to e4
so that is for sure what he's gonna play
he is going to play the move 1 to e4 and
you're gonna respond with 1 to e5 and
now 31 games have continued this way and
then 30 of them XGC has got Knight to f3
so that is to be expected do you see me
actually making the mousse yeah I can
see it and you're gonna respond Knight
to c6 17 games in this point and XGC
plays the same opening every single time
so we will actually be able to prepare
for him he plays what's called the
scotch game I think acara might have
taught him that he plays the move d4
okay now in one game or sorry in two
games xqc played Bishop to c4 the
Italian game and I'm gonna show you a
couple of moves in this position just to
be sure
maybe he Carver will prepare him or
something like that let's actually start
with that to get it out of the way do
you know what to do in this position as
black right yes um so he's threatening
the f7 pawn is it just simply pushing up
so move like I don't know so he's not
actually threatening it's defended by
the King so actually you can just
develop symmetric leadership cc5 just
because he's putting pressure on it
doesn't mean you wanted to necessarily
go out of your way to defend it okay so
you go Bishop c5 in this position xcc
castles and now you just develop your
knight to f6 and in this position in one
of the games that reached this position
xqc played the move d4 and I'm pretty
sure he Cara taught him this opening
which is on a low level a good opening
but I'm gonna show you what to do he
goes d4 okay this looks like a blunder
he's not there tell me you're not seeing
anything no you are you're okay this is
a trap if you take this with the pawn he
has the move e5 with a very nasty attack
against your knight
okay if you take with the night he takes
back on e5 but there's one piece you can
take with that doesn't allow him to do
anything and that is what oh and
actually actually I can flip the board I
forgot we're facing black that should be
easier for you if you actually flip the
board on your ends if you hover over to
the gear should have those three little
buttons yep the third one is the flip
board yep yes that makes sense
what show take that pawn with so is it
taking it with the F night there on the
e4 then he takes your Bishop oh and you
really good at chess you should actually
take the pawn that I've highlighted it
is there questions with what piece and I
made it very hard for you because I've
told you it's not the night and it's not
the woman so it's got to be the bishop
yep and it takes the bishop you take
them Knight and he cannot take because
the pawn is defending it with your other
two and the line goes f4 d6 it's a
defendant he's not gonna know that deep
so basically of course he might watch
the stream but if that's the length that
he goes to that hats off
you're still gonna beat him so just
remember this line and if he defends
this pawn with C three I would go h6
here to stop his Bishop from developing
to g5 in general that's a movie should
keep in mind okay because a lot of
people when they can't develop the
bishop to this square they start
panicking and doing stupid [ __ ] then you
develop as you know how d6 Bishop c4
castles normal developing move so that's
the Italian but xqc will most likely
play sorry the move t4 so here you take
the point okay this is called the scotch
game it's a legitimate opening and it's
not very common at his level so that's
why it's important for you to know what
to do and what do you think why should
you here like what strikes you is the
most logical move I'm no simple I forgot
to push the talk sorry for why they
should just take pawn with Knight yes
and that's what FCC has done and seven
games of his have reached this position
and let me think about ooh give me I
actually have to decide what variation
to show you that's gonna be most likely
okay I know what I'm showing you I know
what I'm [ __ ] showing you that's okay
I'm gonna give you an option on two
options I can show you sort of the safe
line which is guaranteed to give you a
normal pretty decent position or I can
show you a line that might allow you to
score very quick knockout all right
progessive [ __ ] so the super aggressive
[ __ ] is to move your queen out to h4 but
you'll have to do some remembering
the one thing and this is a bit of a
gamble because if he knows exactly how
to react to this line then the position
gets very sharp it's not a bad line
actually this is and if you don't like
it I can show you the other line
okay so Queen h4 what is the idea of the
sum of what are you threatening to take
now we're looking to attack on that f2
pond but you're not [ __ ] threatening
to take it I'm asking you to take oh
we're looking at the pawn at efore I get
you that's right we want to take the
pawn on e4 with check and that's a very
now an ax pcs game that has reached this
position and you know what let me do
this properly download 100 more of his
games and just make sure he hasn't
reached this more than once this will
take me exactly one more second copy
page then we'll have his 200 latest
games that will give us more Lord data
points and the second part because Queen
h4 is a move that some beginners play
and I'll show you how I actually see
reacted when he reached this position at
one time I see
okay CC recent games paste
okay now let's check if in these other
hundred games I downloaded this this
might have been reached okay downloads
copy paste sorry to keep you waiting no
it's all good man I am there we go you
see so I've actually this right here a
kind of scene slash done this when just
going for those mimi scholars mates
isn't this what are the typical
progressions is when you put your queen
out there and they defend somewhere they
usually leave that pawn hanging right uh
yes and no so okay so still one game the
point of this variation is not only to
deliver the scars made it's also really
to put pressure on this pawn on e4 so
it's like a dual purpose most and
potentially yes you can bring your
bishop out to c2 c5 that is a legitimate
idea
so what xec did the one time you reach
this position is panicked and played the
move g3 and why is this a mistake well
it's a free pawn but it's also showing
his rook he's not got as well yes so the
bad news is he can't defend everything
with Queen to e2 we
the move he did not find in the one time
he reached this position he played night
to eat soon after Queen takes h1 he died
a horrible death oh yeah so it looks
gross we need to basically forces you to
capture his queen and then he can
capture with his knight and now you get
an endgame where you're a pawn up and
you have an overwhelming advantage but
it is an endgame so that's sort of
possibility but just because the Queens
are off the board doesn't mean you don't
adhere to general principle so you just
develop your pieces you castle you put
the Rokon an open file and you just
develop all of your pieces I mean do you
feel come true think you'll feel
comfortable playing a position like this
and mind you you're playing HCC who also
doesn't have experience and then games
yeah I think this is something that I
need to do it like at least try in a
game first to see how it feels but on
paper that seems pretty standard stuff
so if when I do take on e4 if they do
block with the Queen the only viable
option is trading them there's no other
way there is unfortunately no other way
this line if X is he finds Queen e2 you
have to trade Queens so this this is a
deal breaker I could show you the other
line it's not like the other line is a
[ __ ] line I could show you like what
the idea is and the other line is to
play Bishop c5 here develop it and
attack the knight and after he takes the
knight you capture the knight and you
actually get a very strong fish up here
then you develop your pieces normally
I'll show you the ideas in this position
as well do you have like sort of an
instinct about what you want to do out
of these two things because way xqc
reacted to this line is also really
shitty I always do prefer like the
aggressive approach it's just the
Trading Queens that early is something I
feel might [ __ ] me up okay um if it
comes to that if he doesn't play that
Queen then that's gonna feel like some
big dick like moves I just feel like I'd
probably panic as well this is also kind
of a big dish so let's stick with Bishop
c5 you know what it's safer it's more
fundamentally sound you'll feel more at
ease that would be my my instinct so
exci see had this twice okay I know it
the first move the first time you played
c3 and this is a big mistake because
instead of developing his pieces he's
guarding the knight but what other
drawback does this move have just some
positional training what is moving he's
not blocking anything so he can't move
that and he's blocking the knight is you
know he's blocking the night and now you
keep developing Knight to f6
you are attacking the pawn and he
probably already in this position has to
take your knight on c6 now which pawns
you take the knight with you take it
with the bee pollen to free up the
bishop yeah so people in my chat by the
way are asking me to show you a
different line where in this position
you play Queen to f6 you actually don't
capture the night and this threatens
checkmate in once so there is a
possibility xqc will miss this mate
but if White knows what to do again he
plays Queen f3 and you have to entertain
the possibility of going into an endgame
you can take the Queen with a knight but
that's just not a great line so it's too
risky I think I think xqc might find
that move so I would not do that if I
were you unless you feel like xdc might
let her mate I was so I was actually
googling like ways to make scholars made
more efficient I really do feel like
this could get him but if he pushes pawn
up is that position where my queen is
like where my queen is there is that a
better position or is that still just
not even worth so you can play this yeah
this is a good move now Knight f6 is
probably the best move Queen f6 is a
very decent move because he might take
your knight that's actually possible and
Miss maiden one imagine what what what
that would create the problem is again
if he knows what to do he plays Bishop
to e3 here then Queen f6 is a slightly
inaccurate move we basically transfer
transpose into theory but I would you
know what why don't you risk it I would
just risk it oh and if he goes Bishop e3
there's one thing I want you to remember
which is that you see your Bishop is
undefended and unprotected can you move
your Bishop to a square so that it's
much better defended by your pawns yeah
just drop it back to drop it back to b6
now the Queen's blocking the Knights
development but that's okay because
where can your knight actually develop
itself to the e7 b7 square now could you
tell me this let's say he develops and
castles and you castle
and he develops now it's already hard
for him to develop he's probably gonna
take your knight on sea
interesting question what do you think
keeping in mind the fact that you want
to develop as quickly as possible which
pond should you take the night with that
should be the deep on right that opens
the file exactly here I mean you're just
sharp just everything is correct you're
too opening up the bishop now this Queen
could then park itself on g6 and skewer
the King and attack the pond the Queen
belongs on g6 here and I'm telling you a
lot you can obviously review this on
your own as well I know I'm giving you a
lot of information here so Queen f6 is
an excellent move here if you play c3 no
effects you see takes the knight are you
still in the mood to play Queen f6 here
and risk it I think yeah I think so I
think it's definitely worth it so if X
EC does find the correct move Queen f3
if you want to avoid the Queen trade
here which is not necessarily advisable
from an objective point of view but you
can do it Queen takes c6 and now if xqc
develops the knight on c3 do not play
the move d6 to develop your Bishop white
that traps my queen yes it should be 5
exactly so that's something you should
remember I would actually put the knight
on e7 here so that your queen has the
possibility of then jumping out to Chi 6
you know FCC will develop you guys will
both develop and hear this idea that you
like to fianchetto in your Bishop I like
it here because the bishop occupies the
long diagonal and potentially will
skewer the Queen and then you can
reroute your queen of g6 and start kind
of attacking we can practice these
positions a little bit more but that's
sort of the basic idea what other moves
could xec play on this and people will
be so impressed that you know this
theory trusts me that's good that's what
it's all about I even care about winning
as long as someone's impressed
exactly exactly who cares about the
result now what if X key C plays Bishop
to e3 what comes to mind here well now I
need to protect the bishop right cuz
it's hanging right but you can also do
what to ruin his pawn structure could
just take with the pawn and now again I
would take with the deep on opening up
your bishop so when you can you can take
with the D pawn and develop along the
scheme a problem with Queen f3 the main
in this position is actually to take the
night but with the pawn but that allows
the queen trade so because you want to
avoid the Queen trade that's the move
I'm advising you to play okay I mean I'm
not totally against the Queen play I
guess if I can get enough games under my
belt where this happens I'm just kidding
yeah I know what you mean though and I
actually agree with you I think even if
it means making a slightly inferior move
keeping you're a better tactical player
so even that it's it's a better cost
benefit I would say you know but I
understand what you're saying we'll try
to get some more practice shortly with
the Queen's off the board just in
general it's a good idea okay so what
else is there in this position if Bishop
to e3 then you actually can play Queen
f6 transposing into the line we just
looked at and if FX you see takes the
knight can you remind me what you do in
this position yeah you take with the
b-pawn are you sure about that oh this
is confidence in me immediately forget
yeah take bishop take the bishop then
take the pawn with a Depot
yeah opening up so everything you said
there was wrong but that's okay
and also remember hanging pawns hanging
pieces always look at what's hanging
here ecstasy might blunder this bond and
that's a disastrous pawn because he
might go on to lose his rook so that's
the key that's gonna win you the match
is this
so Queen to f6 he might also I don't
know what he seemed I don't want to
spend too long like speculating but the
key is to remember Queen to f6 and if he
plays pawn to f3 that he's never gonna
be able to castle the key is then to
prioritize rapid development of your
pieces so that's sort of the rundown in
the opening I don't think there's
anything else you can throw on you in
terms of opening traps that will really
scare you that much so what we can
actually do we can look at more of his
games to look at his weaknesses but I've
kind of gotten a sense of how he plays
he's learned the principles he will
develop his pieces he will castle but he
will make a lot of blunders and he will
do stupid [ __ ] like he will occasionally
start moving as pawns he'll fall in love
with some idea so as long the person who
sticks to the principles better
in this game is that sounding reasonable
so far that sounds about right - no I
mean yeah that's what I did with hutch
fundamentals until the very end
exactly and you've got a great position
fundamentals not missing blunders well
that's all order for you but yeah we can
there's a couple things we can do you
can jump back into the pool and get more
practice in general we can practice this
specific position where we can practice
we can practice for example let's say
this position I can basically ask
someone in my chat to challenge you who
is rated approximately FCC's rating I'm
sure we can find someone and we can sort
of 0and on how to play these positions
and he will unsure graciously play this
out or you can like jump just back in
the pool or we can do more training what
floats your boat what do you have the
Jones for oh I say we go in blind see
what someone like bowel retour SEC lalar
G please let's do it I like it I like it
I'm gonna follow you and yeah I'm still
following you so you can jump right into
the pool okay hold on one second I gotta
go say hello to my girlfriend I'll be
back salutely in just a minute I'm gonna
fill up a water tube so actually I'll be
right back I said I need to run in the
bathroom
sir I have to say hello to the toilet
okay thank you guys for all the
compliments I'm sorry Ivan acknowledge
you guys but thanks everyone who's
watching I hope you guys are enjoying
and thanks everyone for all the subs and
all the support really appreciate it
folks okay
yeah
oh I forgot my water Thank You Coco
appreciate it
guys are very sweet so mattress
Charlie's mattress tomorrow
yeah
but I have a lot of faith in Charlie
he's just so much sharper he's seeing
all the all the tactics I'm I'm happy
I'm confident what rating do you
recommend buying chess piece I would say
around 1415 Andre you can start
considering really you need it if you're
eighteen hundred and above or so is a
Caro training XD see right now
that's hilarious they might be looking
at no he's not trading him right now
though okay he's not your cards not
streaming right now oh good nice the the
prodigies back don't worry I'm hopping
in hahaha so I had the greatest of
thoughts while I'm on the bathroom
peeing mhm
I've watched my fair share of exbc
playing chess and you know Bing Bing
boom and that kind of stuff oh you
started okay okay we'll talk about it
afterward he has a lot of tunnel vision
just that's what I wanted to say she
doesn't notice his tension on the board
and then she won't notice other sides of
the board say he'll blunder these far
moves like Queen takes other font Thank
You quartz extra the sub Wow Chris
Hurley's he's so shocked by this first
move it took him 15 seconds to yeah
almost aborted over man Knight c3 so the
Vienna game man you're playing some
sleep you [ __ ] opponents today Jesus
yeah I don't know why they're moving so
slow I don't really like it so knight c6
and i think you like the four Knights
you can also developer bishop i mean
however you prefer to develop I
typically like to move Bishop out to be
honest so now he does the same um I
don't really need I can still develop
normally right there's nothing I need to
react to here nope you can develop night
yeah symmetrical yeah exactly
yeah no I was clean I would actually
develop your Bishop first I'll explain
why in a moment so developing Bishop
instead of night there no no instead of
castling here I would I wouldn't I would
delay castling maybe that's what you
were gonna do anyway yeah no I was still
gonna be talking about before moving
night doing that doesn't matter yeah
anything there anything works Chris
Hurley so here if he castles you have a
very tricky move that you can actually
make okay so he thinks he's [ __ ] with
this [ __ ] here he attacks your pawn what
comes to mind here
this is Oh oh yeah you have remembered
what you said you want to do the bishop
trick yeah you can do a form of that
here you can actually well I'll let you
try to name the move it's a very very
nice tactic this isn't the legal the
legal is illegal they're just kidding
it's a it's a variation of the sac on f7
you can actually take that point
immediately with the bishop I'll tell
you the move and you can find the follow
up really so you're saying I can
immediately take that F pawn yes I I
don't really know what I'm talking about
usually so I think you should ask me
like five times just so I sure I'm not
[ __ ] but you could have also Castle
it's okay so he takes immediately thinks
you're an idiot now what is the follow
up is it pushing whoa and remember the
fundamental tactical idea here you
trying to explain hanging pieces pieces
that are not defended by any pawns can
be easily picked off and you combine
that with the weakness of blacks King so
when those two come together it
manifests itself in the next move you
should be making I think I'm tunnel
visioning too hard because I don't think
this fits that criteria they think that
I just keep going to is pushing Bishop
out to g5 right so it's not the way
Bishop to g5 it's actually and it's
actually the Knight to g5 so you're
there but what you're not noticing I
think is that the Queen is the one
that's gonna be taking the knight that's
what's hard to notice you don't really
notice the Queen initially do you see
how Knight g5 wins the piece back on g4
I think so I think at the very least
right so ninety five is a check he's got
to move his queen and then you take the
night with your queen
yo Bishop g5 would have just attacked
his queen and then he would have moved
the screen away and then you're down at
peace yeah I see what you're saying so I
did it was beat there'd be like a very
surface level idea without getting too
much out of it exactly
and people wouldn't beginners they're in
love with just attacking pieces and
giving checks but what I try to take to
get across is that it's you can attack a
piece all you want but if it doesn't
serve a purpose then big [ __ ] he just
moves the piece back away okay so
let's see it anything coming to mind
this there is a hanging piece here you
can take it do you see it so why did you
play 95 check what have you opened and
again this is detecting small changes in
the position look at all of your pieces
all of them not just the bishop in the
night look at your queen what is it is
it just taking the message yes no
something a little more aggressive well
you've won a [ __ ] buy me whatever
what else do you want from me I guess my
problem is now I'm thinking to big
scheme like I can't think for like knife
at the throat right and that's that's a
good attitude to have actually and
that's why I think you're a good
attacking player but you have to be you
know there's this phrase masters
celebrate small victories look at what
you've done you've won a pawn not only
back look at his King his King is
incredibly weak so you have to be
patient you're not gonna check meet him
until you bring all your pieces in the
attack okay so he goes ninety four he
goes after your pawn on c2 and this is
where I would actually suggest a
sacrifice because the way I would think
about this position and I won't tell you
the move is let him [ __ ] choke on
that pawn on c2 I'm going to bring all
my pieces in the attack in the meantime
while he's distracted taking all those
pawns so so is what you're thinking the
Knight to d5 to push him up oh that's a
brilliant move actually do it I didn't
even notice that move because it's AK
rifice a rook yes yes that's a great
move that's a great move I was a
combination of the legal straight leg
always trial show you I forgot to show
you though I'll show you the actual
legal strap yep so he thinks he's the
[ __ ] now where would you move your king
moving him up to free up the rank for
rook
yes I will move it to d1 so as not to
block the bishop on c1 should you need
it services later and also to attack the
knight so that he's compelled to capture
your rook and then you're actually
winning okay so moving the d1 is the
better move yep and after he takes your
hook which is a certainty to me because
he thinks he's winning I want I won't
say anything I'll just find the move you
are winning the game
with two possible moves so I want to run
it by you first first move pushing the
Queen to f5 it is and the second move is
basically the same thing just different
square yep you could have also put it to
f3 and she has to give up his queen man
your dog like that move if she really
enjoyed that one 95 I didn't see it and
notice what the knight is doing on t5
had the knight not been there he would
have blocked with his queen on f6 no
hablas on as it stands you're gonna
capture that we now Annie posting key a
holy smokes you're on fire yeah I'm
feeling it so no this is checkmate right
if I just push Queen the f7 yes yeah 12
move win so let's quickly analyze this
before you jump back in just so I can
show you the legals made and stuff
you'll see another anybody if that's
okay with you yeah by all means I will
invite you and you very nice very nice I
mean again if you play like this he has
no chance this is like a pretty this
will make it to like all the dirt all
the chess journals okay actually I'm
pretty proud of that that's gonna go on
my chess resume I found to move that
turbo Geum Daniel Nora didn't even see
people in my chatter going crazy today I
mean they're like who is this guy
honorary GM title so you played all this
da da da da now could you tell me this
if you didn't have this move Bishop
takes f7 what would be the most sort of
safest way of defending this bottom and
developing your pieces at the same time
is it just bringing the rook to f1 yes
but you want to castle like while you're
adding you might as well make your King
safe and what people often don't
understand is they think this is good
for black but it's terrible for black
rook for two pieces is good for the two
pieces and then his King is you can just
pounce on him bring the Knight to g5
bring the Queen to h5 he's busted here
right so don't be afraid of this tension
on the pawn because later on you could
chase the night away with h2 if you want
it he has no way of reinforcing the
attack on the f2 pawn I don't know how
that sounds to do if that makes sense
definitely now let's talk about what is
the classical legal strap now legals
mates and its name
after a French player for the 18th
century surprisingly his name was legal
I mean I don't know if it's it might be
illegal for me to reveal his name but I
think he's dead now he's definitely long
in the ground this move probably killed
him his magnum opus
oh yeah and legal played an unknown
player that's how the trap originated
and the unknown player played g6 here in
this position to fianchetto the bishop
and here legal initiated legals mate
maybe you can tell me that is the move
you wanted to play initially you can
play it here what is it that's so that's
what I was thinking so with this you
push the knight here yes you look the
Queen and now what yes Jami and there is
many variations of this line I mean
there's many ways the black can fall
into it black has many ways of not
following into one of them being Knight
to f6 could you explain to me why Lea
bells made is not possible here and I'd
like you to name both reasons here just
as a tactical kind of exercise because
the knight will defend so if I give up
this and he takes that and then I come
here this is a force move but then he
can take this precisely that's the main
reason and in this position he can even
do something simple
yeah and cut the cut the nuts off legal
hey there's no legal to deliver the mate
with the air if he does that yeah it's
just taking this yeah taking the knight
and the Knights defeated the bishop now
you couldn't have done that here because
what he could he should but then you
take the bishop and you're up upon and
you've got all the advantages of your
position here right so yeah so that's
legals mate and here I mean you can't do
anything of that nature but it's a
similar tactic you take on f7 draw his
King out and win the knight and yes okay
had he played it the move d6 here what
would you have done just out of
curiosity I would have dropped Queen
back to f3 yes with check or you could
have dropped it even to t1 then Castle
then then opened the FL we'll talk about
that in a second so you play 94 another
move that I had in mind was simply to
Castle and Knight 62 okay if you want to
see the real five head move here like
real five bedrooms how would I think
about this position now I feel like
you're tempted by giving
to give a check here right initially
yeah the problem is he blocks with the
Queen and that's why 95 your move was so
brilliant because then it towards the
pawn but the way I would think about
this is imagine if the f2 pawn that I
just highlighted disappeared from the
board it was gone
do you see how much that would benefit
your attack oh the huge I have a whole
file on you just we just tear him to
bits could you devise a scheme to try to
open up that file and it doesn't have to
be one move it can be three moves but do
you see any way of opening that file I
mean the simplest one would just be well
I can't push the pawn up since the
bishops got it so you're almost there
you thought you that's the right way to
start this so I miss being pinned by the
by the bishop how do you unbend yourself
oh yeah you just block with the D pawn
well then he takes the D pawn and we're
in the same situation
oh well it's a very subtle move it thank
you for finally saying something true
with the bishop that is the best move it
should be and then if she takes you open
up the file right you could also this is
like six head King h1 this is like a GM
level move on painting yourself with a
king it looks like you're full of crap
because he'd give up the rope but after
half for no probably black is fine here
if he defends like a computer but he
cannot stop you from opening up the F
file so King h1 would be I move the like
a grandmaster would consider but it
makes perfect sense you just want to
play a four I can't do it why I'm pins
let's unfit ourselves with Bishop e3 is
even better because if he takes the rook
now wait what can you do you take the
knight nope don't take the knight
because that would actually be counter /
that would be cross purposes because
then your rook would not be able to
occupy the F file immediately so you
just take the bishop the first take the
bishop maybe this is a little bit
complicated goes d6 to attack your queen
that's why I actually like King h1 here
and then okay where so that would have
been good but instead you played this
move he should have probably chased your
night away with c6 instead the X you see
would take on c2 take on anyone this is
called setting a trap and this is what
I'd like you to try to do on the night
because if you're able to tempt him into
thinking that you've wondered something
and you see a head that's like the
shortcut to winning again right I don't
know if you did you see that it can take
your rope well yeah and you've got
that's that's awesome and that's exactly
how you win the game and here you should
have give it a squeeze up but you're
[ __ ] him here anyway
alright so hopefully you'll get black in
the next game so we'll be able to to
practice those types of openings so I
don't curiosity what what I saw with the
knight and d5 was looking at a checkmate
I didn't even consider the Queen pushing
up and how it defended that so how would
you when I pointed that out how is that
one of the first things you saw what was
like yeah you considered well it's it's
really I I go from first principles
there's three ways of blocking it up
dealing with a check three and only
three at any given check number one
moving the King number two to capture
the piece that is delivering the check
number three
blocking the check I now I don't
consciously go through all three and ask
myself can the beast be captured is
there a way to block the check this
process occurs self-consciously but for
you it is worth asking yourself the
three critical questions and if you ask
yourself can he block this check my
guess is you would then sequin of six
and then you have to evaluate is this a
reason not to give the check right here
it's not but if my advice is most people
have around your level they see a check
and they actually miss ways of blocking
the check that's not something that
comes naturally you kind of assume that
the King has to be moved as Chris or as
the great Chris early did yes Chris
Hurley the household name of just a
right of course that every at every
dinner conversation between grandmasters
the name is mentioned its author of
multiple manuals on how to deal with
checks actually Hurley's early methods
of disarming a check but the book is
empty sold out immediately but yeah so
literally ask yourself can the check be
blocked when you're giving a check and
am i defending the blocking square so
here that's the idea of 95 that's why I
was so impressed by that move because
you're thinking ahead to the point where
the night guards that squid square on
which the check can be blocked all right
okay cool so hopefully that makes sense
but 12 move game I mean
alright I'll take that a speedrun I'm
going for it I want to eat his recess I
mean I think you should go for 3,000 I
mean that's not a very impressive rating
to begin with you know
so just hop back and not back in let's
see it alright wow this man from
Paraguay said back waiting you know said
Mike wheel he's trying to intimidate
with his name yeah I see that it's not
gonna work
let's hope he plays the Scotch that
would be pretty cool so the is he
looking for a Petrov here so then this
nice decent I mean it's not like people
are expecting the Petrov it's just oh it
does oh this is nice
so then I take that right with the pond
yeah maybe he was watching my stream
that would be hilarious
okay so let's hope he takes for the
night okay do you remember the movie so
is it I do remember the move but is it
Bishop or queen first it's Bishop to c5
first so here you adhere to the
principles Bishop develops first because
you want to be flexible right if the
Queen develops you're committing the
Queen to that spot right and if he takes
the knight that's where okay he doesn't
take the night he goes Knights b5 now
now here if you develop your queen
immediately that might okay you can set
a vicious trap here if you really want
to you can't please really zoning in on
this fort for the rook to watch that
tunnel vision happen if you play Queen
f6 I guarantee you he'll be like this
idiot blunder the pawn on c7 that would
actually be a mistake because I win the
game it's a checkmate oh but you might
take c7 is a check but do you see what
I'm saying if he takes the knight out of
pawn on c7 that's also a check but then
you move your king and you're
simultaneously attacking the knight and
attacking the pawn an f2 yeah okay so
you can if you I would not move the
Queen up there just because if he
defends the mate it's not a great idea
but I would risk it let's see if he
falls into it I I'm pretty certain he's
already committed I don't think he's
looking back there I'm pretty sure he's
just gonna go right in he might smell a
rat though that's the thing oh my god he
does not you're right and now you see
where to put the Queen of the King yes
and I just moved the King and this is
pretty much game over yeah well I mean
he if he doesn't take oh my god he blood
his baby
look at it look at this I couldn't even
believe it see you have a better
understanding of these players than I do
this is hilarious we discussed this and
then it literally happens yeah because
like I said I do the same [ __ ] like I'll
see something and I won't think of
what's being opened up or what someone's
prepping for like Bishop right there is
just a fundamental move exactly it's not
necessarily doing anything right away
but the second I moved my queen I would
have I wouldn't even considered it if I
was in a position of fork exactly and
it's almost like yeah this television
might be the greatest source of airs
it's like once you train it's like
you're a sniper when you're when you're
geom you're running around you know and
kind of shooting everyone when you're
600 you're like a sniper but not in a
good sense your training and training
and training of crosshairs and training
them and then you see the target and you
shoot the target but you have no clue
about the 10 people that have approached
you from behind yeah I'm coming around
for that back door reach around every
single time so you need to find those
moves again sexy see how can I convince
him that I've blundered he'll be like
bing bang boom I'm taking the rook and
winning Oh
checkmate yeah that's oh my god I would
not so hard if that